digamos que tienes una serie s muy bien
que no es otra cosa más que una suma
infinita verdad es la suma infinita
desde n igual a 1 hasta infinito de los
términos a n y esto sólo es una forma
digamos compacta de escribir que estamos
sumando a uno con a dos más a tres y así
sumamos todos estos términos por siempre
verdad es bueno porque son una infinidad
de términos muy bien entonces lo que
quiero hacer en este vídeo es
introducirte a la idea de lo que es una
suma parcial ok y lo que tenemos aquí es
una serie mientras que una forma parcial
por ejemplo sería ésta la sexta suma
parcial la sexta suma parcial sería
sumar los primeros seis términos de esta
serie entonces tendríamos a uno más a
dos más a tres
4 + a 5 + a 6 así de fácil esto es una
suma parcial y a lo mejor esto está muy
abstracto porque no sabe uno quién son
los agenes entonces vamos a hacer un
caso más concreto digamos que nuestra
serie es la suma desde n igual a 1 hasta
infinito y nuestros genes estarán dados
por 1 entre n cuadrada muy bien entonces
esto me está diciendo bueno por ejemplo
cuando n vale 1 tenemos 1 entre 1 al
cuadrado y eso vale 1 cuando en el vale
2 tenemos 1 entre 2 al cuadrado que es
un cuarto y cuando n vale 3 tenemos 1
entre 3 al cuadrado que es un noveno y
así seguimos sumando todos estos
términos verdad todos estos términos
entonces la pregunta sería por ejemplo
cuál es
el valor de la tercera suma parcial y
como siempre te invito a que hagas una
pausa y trates de resolver este problema
por tu propia cuenta
entonces ahora vamos a hacerlo juntos
muy bien entonces el primer término
habíamos visto que era 1 el segundo
término era 1 entre 2 al cuadrado que es
un cuarto y el tercer término como ya
vimos es un noveno entonces cuánto vale
esta suma bueno tenemos que encontrar un
denominador común que puede ser 36 y un
entero son 36 sobre 36 verdad un cuarto
son 9 sobre 36 simplemente hacemos 36
entre 4 que son 9 y luego 36 entre 9 son
4 por 1 son 4 guardar un noveno son 4
entre 36 entonces si sumamos esto
tenemos 36 más 4 que son 40 más 9 son 49
sobre 36 muy bien entonces este es el
valor explícito de la tercera suma
parcial que surge a partir de esta serie
muy bien entonces el objetivo de este
vídeo en realidad es apreciar la idea de
lo que es
una suma parcial y vamos a hacer otro
ejercicio para seguir practicando que
íbamos a quitar todo esto y digamos que
nuevamente tenemos una serie que es la
suma desde n igual a 1 hasta infinito de
los términos a n
pero ahora digamos que nuestro nuestra
enésima suma parcial tiene una fórmula y
digamos que es n cuadrada menos 3 sobre
n cúbica más 4 muy bien y recordemos
quién es ese en nuestra enésima suma
parcial es sumar todos los términos de
esta serie a 1 + a 2 hasta llegar al
enésimo término al n y esto nos está
diciendo que es n cuadrada menos 3 sobre
n cúbica más 4 muy bien entonces digamos
que te encuentras a alguien en la calle
y ese alguien no sé a lo mejor sabe que
tú ya conoces sobre sumas parciales y te
dice bueno suponte que tenemos esta
serie s
ahí tenemos esta serie ese y tenemos la
fórmula de las sumas parciales tú
podrías decirme quién es la suma desde n
igual a 1 hasta 6 de los genes entonces
podrías intentarlo por tu cuenta de
hecho te invito a que lo hagas pero por
ahora vamos a hacerlo nosotros juntos
verdad entonces recordemos que esto
simplemente es a uno más a dos más a
tres más a cuatro más a cinco más a seis
estamos simplemente sumando los primeros
seis términos
así que si nosotros le ponemos mucho ojo
a esta expresión simplemente podemos ver
que es la sexta suma parcial verdad
estamos sumando desde a 1 hasta a 6
verdad que corresponde como esta fórmula
que tenemos aquí sin embargo tenemos que
ese 6 se puede calcular mediante esta
fórmula y está verdad en este caso sería
6 al cuadrado menos 3 dividido entre 6
al cubo
+ 4 muy bien entonces ahora simplemente
nos queda calcular esto y entonces 6 al
cuadrado es 36 si le quitamos 3 son 33 y
dividimos entre 6 al cubo más 46 al cubo
sería 6 por 6 que son 36 y 36 por 6
serían 3 por 6 son 18 verdad son 186 por
6 son 36 y la suma nos da 61 y llevamos
una verdad 8 y 3 son 11 1 y 1 son 2
entonces son 216 más 4
esos son 220 y entonces aquí tenemos la
expresión para la sexta suma parcial muy
bien así que con este vídeo el objetivo
era realmente conocer la anotación de lo
que son las sumas parciales y entender
realmente lo que significan